AS WE LEFT.
>> Laura: I THOUGHT YOU WERE
GOING TO SAY, SHERIFF, HE LOOKED
UP AND WAVED, "HI."
>> HE DID, BUT HE DIDN'T USE HIS
WHOLE HAND WHEN HE WAVED.
>> Laura: I GOTCHA.
HAVE A GREAT EASTER WEEKEND.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOWED NO SIGNS
OF BACKING DOWN ON HIS PROMISE
TO BUILD A BORDER RALLY AT A
RALLY IN RICHMOND OHIO TODAY.
>> DRUGS ARE FLOWING ACROSS
BORDERS.
WE NEED WALLS.
WE START BUILDING OUR WALL, I'M
SO PROUD OF IT.
WE ALREADY STARTED, YOU SAW THE
PICTURES TODAY, I SAID WHAT A
THING OF BEAUTY, AND ON
SEPTEMBER 28TH, WE GO FURTHER,
AND WE GET THAT SUCKER BILLS.
YOU THINK THAT'S EASY?
PEOPLE SAY, AS HE GIVEN UP ON
THAT WALL?
I NEVER GIVE UP.
>> Laura: THE RECENT REPORTS
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
CONSIDERING HAVING THE MILITARY
PAY FOR THE WALL.
JOINING ME FOR REACTION,
LIEUTENANT COLONEL MICHAEL WALL.
THIS IS A FILED SITUATION NOW.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THAT TODAY, I
THINK IT WAS
"THE WASHINGTON POST," MADE UP
IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES," TONIGHT
SAID THAT THAT IS NOT TRUE,
NOTHING IS UNDER WAY, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT HE IS TALKING ABOUT.
MEANWHILE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE WONDERING, WHAT IS GOING ON?
WITH NATIONAL SECURITY, WITH
HUMANITARIAN PROBLEMS, WITH THE
ECONOMIC PROBLEM, WITH THE
STRAIN ON OUR BUDGET.
YOU SEE WHAT IS GOING ON IN
CALIFORNIA, THE HOMELESSNESS.
WHY CAN'T WE ENFORCE OUR BORDER?
IS THERE NO WILL TO DO IT?
I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS THE
WILL BUT CONGRESS DOESN'T SEEM
TO THINK SO.
>> FIRST, THE PRESIDENT IS
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
BORDER SECURITY IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUE.
LOOK, A PIPELINE THAT CAN MOVE
IMMIGRANTS AND CAN MOVE DRUGS
CAN ALSO MOVE WMDs COME ON,
TERRORISTS, AND CAN MOVE
WEAPONS.
AND WE KNOW THAT HEZBOLLAH IS
ALL OVER SOUTH-CENTRAL AMERICA,
IS WORKING WITH MEXICAN DRUG
GANGS, HAS BELOW OPERATIVE WAS
CONVICTED IN 2011 FOR WORKING
WITH THE MEXICAN DRUG GANG IN
ORDER TO SMUGGLE DRUGS IN AND
ASSASSINATE A SAUDI AMBASSADOR,
SO HE IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IN FACT, THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE AND MILITARY, BOTH
NATIONAL GUARD AND ACTIVE-DUTY,
ARE SUPPORTING I.C.E., ARE
SUPPORTING LAW ENFORCEMENT ALL
UP AND DOWN OUR BORDERS.
THE ISSUE HERE IS PAYING FOR IT,
AND IN ORDER TO REPROGRAM
FRONTS, YOU HAVE TO GO BACK TO
CONGRESS.
YOU CAN MOVE RELATIVELY SMALL
AMOUNTS, BUT IN ORDER TO
BILLIONS, LIKE WHAT IS ESTIMATED
TO BUILD THE WALL, YOU'RE GOING
TO
HAVE TO GO BACK TO CONGRESS.
IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN NEGOTIATED
IN THE CURRENT BILL.
>> Laura: IT IS INFURIATING ON
MULTIPLE LEVELS THAT THAT WAS
NOT AN ABSOLUTE MUST IN THE
OMNIBUS.
BUT WE KNOW, COLONEL  , THAT
PAUL RYAN, MITCH McCONNELL,
MANY OTHERS IN THE LEADERSHIP
AND OTHER MAINSTREAM REPUBLICANS
AND OTHER MAINSTREAM REPUBLICAN
REPUBLICANS, THEY DON'T WANT A
WALL.
THEY DIDN'T WANT A WALL, THEY
ARE HAPPY WITH SENSORS OR
DRONES.
THEY DO NOT WANT A WALL.
THEY DON'T LIKE THE IMAGERY OF
THE WALL.
THEY THINK IT MAKES US LOOK
LIKE, YOU KNOW, EAST GERMANY.
THEY DON'T WANT IT.
THEY NEVER WANTED IT.
TRUMP RAN ON IT AND WON IN PART
ON THAT WALL, IN LARGE PART ON
THAT WALL, AND I THINK, COME
HELL OR HIGH WATER, HE STARTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT IS BUILT FOR
HIS FUTURE.
>> YOU KNOW, LAURA, THERE IS
THIS INTERESTING QUESTION OF,
CAN HE DECLARE A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY OF WHAT IS GOING ON ON
OUR BORDER.
MUCH LIKE WHAT HAPPENS IN A
HURRICANE OR ANOTHER NATURAL
DISASTER OR A RIOT, AND
FEDERALIZE TROOPS, FEDERALIZE
THE NATIONAL GUARD, AND USE THEM
IN THIS CASE?
AGAIN, WHAT HAPPENED IN THOSE
CASES IS, THERE IS A QUICK
CONVERSATION WITH CONGRESS AND
THE PRESIDENT MOVES FORWARD
UNDER HIS EXECUTIVE AUTHORITY,
AND THEN THE APPROPRIATE AT
LATER.
THERE IS A LOT OF DISCUSSION ON
WHETHER HE CAN DECLARE THIS IN A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY AND DO IT.
>> Laura: YOU THINK IT WILL
TIE HIM UP IN THE COURTS?
THEY ARE GOING TO TRY TO SUE THE
ADMINISTRATION, A PRELIMINARY
INJUNCTION, AND INJUNCTIVE
RELEASE, STOP HIM FROM DOING
THAT, IT'S GOING TO GET ALL TIED
UP.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY, ITSELF
MAKE YOUR ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN NEGOTIATED IN
THE BILL.
>> Laura: YOU KNOW MATTIS, I
CAN'T IMAGINE MATTIS IS WILD
ABOUT THIS.
IT'S BEEN CONFIRMED THAT THEY
WERE RUNNING BACK THE GENERAL
COUNSEL.
I THINK THAT IS WINDOW DRESSING
TO PLACATE THE PRESIDENT.